[Applause]
of new kids
on the block
after weeks of teasing viewers with
clues on the masked singer
the rooster cluemaster cloodledoo
revealed his identity during wednesday's
and let's just say that the unmasking
left panelist
jenny mccarthy totally shook and boom
cloodle dew was a new addition to this
season
a masked performer who never sang but
dished
out clues and hints about the identities
of the contestants
while the show teased that cloodle do
himself
was actually a big celebrity too
that's awesome well on wednesday the
rooster flipped the script again
and performed return of the mac by mark
morrison
and he freaking crushed it
jenny and her fellow panelists robin
thicke nicole scherzinger
ken jung and guest panelist darius
rucker
all did their best to figure out who is
behind the mask
i am doubling down on jamie foxx yeah
i think it's kevin james wow his tone
reminded me of akon so i think this
could be acon
yeah none of them were right and jenny
was
totally shocked by the reveal
oh my god yep that's
jenny's hubby donny wahlberg two reasons
why i'm here honestly uh
one obviously to see my wife and two
you know it's been so long since i
performed for my fans and new kids on
the block fans affectionately known as
blockheads they're like
they're family like they're my heart and
when jenny who was
totally floored asked how he managed to
keep it all a secret
he had this to say you've been coming in
each week in life i've been sneaking in
and out
jenny spoke to e.t back in march near
the start of season five
and straight up shut down any
speculation people might have about
donny competing on the show
i keep wanting it to happen myself
obviously we keep bringing his name up
donnie is still on blue bloods and
until he's done with blue bloods i would
say
he's there's not really a chance for him
to be on
um and then of course with cobid there's
rules about
going in and out so you'll just have to
wait there will be a season
so don't give up hope i'm keeping my
fingers crossed
so you just gotta wait until blue blood
is a wrapped
or maybe who knows when this covey
thing's over maybe they can make some
[Music]
room
you